the M16 is one of the most recognizable
weapons to come from the Western world
but while this iconic firearm had a
troubled start to its history it has
since cemented itself as an essential
part of video game arsenals and is
widely viewed as a good guy gun in
Western pop culture
while it's appeared in hundreds of
movies TV shows and video games why does
the M16 have such a legendary reputation
and with its plethora of models and long
firearm ancestry what impact has this
rifle had on our video games we've come
here to the Royal armories Museum in the
UK to learn a little more about the
history and pop culture Legacy of one of
the most iconic weapons in the world as
well as seeing this classic rifle in
action
[Music]
foreign
the M16 and its family of rifles are one
of the most iconic series of weapons
both throughout history and pop culture
with estimates between 10 and 20 million
rifles produced with only the mozin
again the g98 and of course the AK
series of rifles exceeding that number
the M16 has become one of the world's
most prominent Firearms through its
lifetime of over half a century the
history of the AR-15 or as most people
will know it the M16 which is the U.S
military designation believe it or not
it's from the 1950s and you can kind of
see it in the design it's a sort of
almost a futurist looking bit of Kit
made of what were then Advanced Alloys
and polymers very lightweight but it was
the second attempt essentially the AR-10
was the first attempt an AR standing for
ArmaLite rifle Eugene Stoner was the
designer wonderfully light weapon really
quite controllable with the original
design of muzzle device on there as well
my impression at least is it was just to
sci-fi too lightweight too toy-like for
the US Army of the day so it didn't make
it through trials and they ended up
adopting a sort of warmed over M1 Garand
in the form of the M14 which then ended
up being the shortest service rifle in
the history of the US with only seven
years Frontline service because the
AR-10 came back from the dead as the
AR-15 a huge part of the M16s history
and a moment in time that's conjured up
in many people's minds when talking
about this rifle is of course the
Vietnam War early confrontations between
the AK type weapons and the M14
indicated that American units would
struggle to maintain fire superiority
the M14 was unsuited for the jungle
environment of Vietnam due to its length
and weight and its 7.62 by 51 millimeter
cartridge made the weapon all but
uncontrollable in automatic fire to meet
the military's new needs the AR-10 was
scaled down and adapted to fire the 5.56
by 45 millimeter intermediate cartridge
becoming the AR-15 which after further
modifications was finally adopted as the
M16 but had America found their answer
to the Soviet AK many individuals still
favored their original M14 rifle as the
lightweight and plastic construction of
the M16 had some referring to the weapon
as a toy it also had a grubbing
reputation of poor reliability with a
survey of 1585 soldiers reporting that
approximately half of them had
experienced stoppages while fighting
with their M16 despite the legacy of the
weapon and the rifle it became the rush
to get the M16 into the hands of the
forces in Vietnam meant its early
history was marked by this poor
reputation and a multitude of issues the
main one was in the type of propellant
adopted for the cartridges which was not
what was advised add to that tropical
conditions where corrosion is always
going to be worse they cheaped out on
the chrome plating for the chamber and
the bore of the right of the barrel as
well official advice was that the rifle
was self-cleaning this was a
revolutionary design that did away with
the need for a heavy gas piston moving
back and forth instead it had a very
lightweight tube and that was
self-cleaning but the dirt has to go
somewhere and it went into the bolt
carrier group and just disaster you'll
see photos and video from Vietnam of
soldiers taping
rods cleaning rods to the side of their
rifles because with all that corrosion
and the tropical conditions and the bad
powder the rifle would stop and you'd
have to stop your fighting tell the VC
to just hang on a moment while you stick
a rod down the board bang out the stuck
case absolute nightmare guys were killed
as a result of it and so some veterans
even today will swear blind that this
thing is terrible to help alleviate the
issue of cartridges failing to seat the
Army insisted on adding a forward assist
to the weapon a feature visible
throughout almost every first person
shooter even if in a few cases it's
misplaced or misunderstood
however the U.S Air Force Colt and
Eugene Stone himself believed this was
an unjustified expense so the design was
split into the M16 for the U.S Air Force
and the xm16e1 for the other branches of
military the xm16e1 would be
redesignated as the m16a1 after it
received further improvements such as
the A1 Birdcage flash suppressor with
future versions of this muzzle device
becoming synonymous with the Aesthetics
and design of the weapon system the
rifle's reputation began to grow into a
much more positive one and in 1969 the
m16a1 officially joined the M16 to
replace the M14 at the US military's
standard service rifles the rifle was
later improved upon and modified to
become the m16a2 which also swapped the
full auto function for a three-round
burst Vietnam saw some units including
Special Forces issued with a shorter
carbine version of the M16 the Colt
xm177 car 15 Commando for Close Quarters
battle and the 80s would see a return to
this idea with the development of the
other iconic weapon from the M16 family
the M4 carbine it was easier to carry
and utilize in tight space and close
quarters and was so successful with
Special Operations forces and support
troops that it eventually replaced the
full-length rifle while the M4 shorter
Barrel meant slightly decreased muzzle
velocity which could reduce wounding
effect at longer distances the powers
that be considered that to be an
acceptable compromise after over 90
modifications to improve reliability
ergonomics and modularity the refined M4
in the form of the more robust and fully
automatic capable M4A1 would become the
standard service rifle for the US Army
although in 2022 the xm7 Sig spear won
the Next Generation Squad weapon program
which aims to replace the M4 carbine
with consistent improvements to the
platform wide adoption by countries
across the globe as well as dozens of
different variants and weapons owing
much of their DNA to the AR-15 and M16
rifles this weapon has cemented itself
as one of the most iconic and prolific
weapons in history with such a vast
Legacy and reputation from The Real
World it's highly surprising the M16 has
become such a juggernaut within movies
TV and video games 1964's seven days in
May is a political thriller about U.S
military leaders plotting to overthrow
the president and it also marks the
earliest appearance of the M16 in a
Hollywood film appearing on Cinema
screens months before the weapon even
got into the hands of soldiers fighting
in Vietnam from there the weapon would
go on to feature in hundreds of movies
and TV shows backdrops featuring
military conflicts either fictional or
based on reality would often feature the
American Soldier as the hero with their
M16 rifle in hand sharing some of that
Fame from shootouts between cops and
criminals to action-packed Classic spy
Thrillers and even science fiction and
horror whenever the Silver Screen needed
a rifle the readily available and
recognizable M16 was the obvious choice
which also means they've shared the
spotlight as a part of some of the most
iconic action scenes where on the hands
of some of the biggest stars
the lobby shootout in The Matrix
Arnold's rifle with underslung m203 and
Predator scarface's little friend and of
course that iconic gunfight in 1995's
heat which is a scene so authentic it's
actually shown to Marine recruits as an
example of how to reload and Retreat
Under Fire on the video game front one
of the earliest depictions of the rifle
is in the Punisher capcom's 1993
side-scrolling beat em up where the M16
was an obvious choice for former Marine
Frank Castle in contrast to that comic
book inspired appearance the use of real
world conflicts either as inspiration or
as a setting is extremely common within
our games and the prominence of the M16
throughout those real world events has
been mirrored in the Arsenal of many
shooters games like men of valor Viet
Hong Call of Duty Black Ops shell shock
Armor 3 Rising Storm 2 Vietnam and even
more all offer an opportunity to play
through the war from an American
perspective the same is true for more
modern conflicts as well with many games
taking inspiration from military events
from across the 90s and 2000s titles
like Call of Duty 4 Modern Warfare
Battlefield 2 full spectrum warrior and
many more all took players on Virtual
present day campaigns armed with an M16
or an M4 the more modern M16s and m4s
found within these games allowed players
to virtually tap into the real-life
utility of weapon customization
accessorization and the use of Optics an
element of video games that was quickly
becoming popular some of the accessories
associated with the M16 had even started
to become iconic additions in their own
right attachments like the ACOG Advanced
combat Optical gunsight or the m203
grenade launcher which are now very
familiar accompaniments to the rifle the
M16 was a familiar weapon that was also
a canvas for customization and many
players across the years would have seen
these accessories in movies and across
news reports and would want to recreate
these loadouts and make use of them
themselves of course video game military
fiction is but a fraction of the games
that the M16 has found itself in and
even though it's common for the rifle to
receive a different name or tweaks to
its design there are still so many guns
that are iconic and recognizable as an
M16 the Far Cry series Taps into the
jungle fighting lineage of the weapon
with either the M16 M4 or similar AR-15
type weapon available as an option in
nearly every game in the franchise as
M16s or AR-15 style weapons are
prominent at home as well as abroad they
can also find themselves in the hands of
neduels as a tool of chaos and crime
throughout the Grand Theft Auto
franchise or in the hands of Civilian
survivors fighting across a
zombie-infested America in Lafayette and
speaking of apocalypses it's the perfect
weapon for the new California Republic
of Fallout New Vegas appearing in game
as the service rifle its Aesthetics are
a mixture of AR-10 and AR-15 and if as
many were made in Fallout as there were
in the real world I'm sure plenty would
have survived the bombs dropping and
found themselves in the hands of the
All-American peacekeeping force of the
Mojave while we'll talk more about the
rifle's life and games one thing common
to the M16s time on screen is that it's
almost always seen in the hands of the
hero the winning side or the saviors of
the day we talked about the AK-47 being
portrayed as a bad guy gun in a previous
episode so if there was ever an
antithesis to that weapon in the world
of Pop Culture we any look no further
through its appearances in games TV
shows and movies it's not hard to see
why the M16 falls under the Trope of
good guy gun
we have a very strong Western cultural
Narrative of the us as the the world's
arguable only superpower now ultimately
the leading Force at the end of both
both world wars obviously other nations
strongly contributed and so of course
any weapon that is seen in the hands of
those soldiers is going to get these
positive connotations depending where in
the world you're from and you know what
experience you've had whereas of course
the the classic bad guy was the Soviet
Union and that had this very visually
different weapon even though you could
probably swap weapons from NATO to the
Soviet block and nothing would change
really but it they illustrate design
philosophies simple cheap easy and quick
to produce in large quantity versus more
precise more thinking more about the
user experience the reason why it's so
strongly associated with what we in the
west would call the good guys is it just
everywhere
a virtual Arsenal without an M16 M4 or
similar AR-15 style weapon would almost
feel incomplete but vast appearances and
depictions means that it's left some
very specific Footprints in gaming the
feature most associated with the M16 in
terms of gameplay is that it's often
shown using a three round burst and
while absolutely deadly in some games or
frustratingly lackluster and others this
feature is down to the real world design
of the weapon during the development of
the m16a2 the US forces found that
inexperienced troops would spray under
Fire when using a fully automatic weapon
so they integrated a three-round burst
instead which could provide the optimal
accuracy Firepower and ammunition
conservation while the original M16 A1
and A3 are capable of fully automatic
fire burst fire was core to the design
of the A2 and A4 as well as the original
M4 carbine and in most games it's these
variants that are depicted however they
will most often be complemented by games
offering a similar fully automatic
option for example Battlefield 3
accurately portrayed its m16a3 and M4A1
as capable of being fully automatic
while the M16A4 and M4 are burst burst
fire is one of the ways the M16 can sit
unique among the rest of the firearms in
a game while many players may prefer the
thrill of going full auto a well-placed
three-round burst offers a different
play style for those that would rather a
series of well-placed shots over spray
control the M16 carry handle is Iconic
to the weapon and its aesthetic but it's
also an element that has had an effect
on gameplay as well due to the design
often obscuring your sight picture it
has been common to see players complain
about the M16 iron sights and as a
result quickly swapping them out or
adding an optic at the earliest
convenience but these are just two
elements to name a few that have
influenced more esoteric weapon design
and gameplay balance in a variety of
different titles and genres as Call of
Duty explored more futuristic settings
they knew how familiar their fanbase was
with many of their weapons and that
they'd be able to use design cues and
gameplay in their new fictional weapons
to connect a player with something
similar infinite warfare's nv4 has all
the stylings of a near future M4A1 and
the m8a7 from Black Ops some Aesthetics
like the carry handle and flash hider
that I feel hearken back to the M16 of
previous games the m8a7 in particular
was certainly a weapon that scratched
the itch that burst fire fans were
feeling when that game launched but I
think you can see some of these
recognizable designs and cues in other
games and franchises as well although I
am prepared for some of you to disagree
with me here the M15 Vindicator and m96
matic's angular upper design allows for
just a hint of familiarity in the
bizarre world of Mass Effect especially
with the M15 being another burst fire
weapon many of Borderlands 3's Dar
rifles feature similar carry handles
optic arrangements and Picatinny rails
while many of their weapons also have
the ability to fire in bursts Soldier
76's Knight Ops or Commando skins turn
his pulse rifle into something that is
undeniably a future M16 and while
useless as a sight the carry handle of
Deep Rock galactics drak25 definitely
looks like an M16 or M4 if I drew it
while I was drunk even some of the
weapons of Warhammer 40K have a few
hints of the AR-15 both making a weapon
feel aesthetically familiar while also
pointing to the utilitarian firearms and
stagnant technology of the Imperium of
mankind in the 41st Millennium some
games will also add more peculiar
variants or customization options to
allow for either unique gameplay utility
or varied Gunplay while staying within
that same recognizable platform 2019's
Modern Warfare lets you chamber your M4
in nine millimeter giving you the
in-game equivalent of the real Colt nine
millimeter SMG Rainbow Six Siege
features the ar-1550 an AR-15 converted
to fire the powerful 50 caliber Beowulf
round and 2022's Modern Warfare 2 lets
players use the love child of a P90 and
an AR-15 with the FSS hurricane while
those are obviously not M16s they still
share some of the same DNA as well as a
little of the Legacy virtual appearances
of both the common standard versions of
the weapon as well as the rarer or more
peculiar variants and derivatives shows
that the m16's lineage and impact is
cemented into the minds of players as an
iconic recognizable rifle because of
that the M16 in one form or another will
always have a spot reserved within the
armories of our video games we couldn't
do a video on the AK-47 without doing
one on the M16 both are iconic weapons
not only throughout history but within
our pop culture as well the M16 and M4
have made appearances in hundreds of
games and movies and many shooter fans
have built an affinity or connection
with these weapons as a fan of both I
believe you can't help appreciate the
rifle's history as well as its pop
culture Legacy so whether pure polymer
and metal in the jungles of Vietnam
Twisted into science fiction facsimiles
or decked out with the most modern and
tactical accessories I can't see our
screens ever being without the most
iconic All-American rifle the M16
thank you so much for watching this
episode of Loadout if you enjoyed it
make sure to leave a like subscribe and
let me know in the comment section below
what you'd like to see an episode on or
you can reach out to me directly on
Twitter at a regular day if you want
more video game Weaponry content you can
watch our previous series of this show
or check out our weekly series of
firearms expert reacts where I show our
friends at the Royal armories a
selection of video game arms to break
down until next time Ivan your host Dave
Jewett thank you again for watching and
I will see you in the next episode
[Music]